el presidente López Obrador bajo la
premisa de que el consejo de seguridad
de la ONU estaba paralizado que no había
logrado evitar en primera instancia la
guerra y después llegar a un una
solución del conflicto bélico propuso en
su momento un plan que consistía en
crear un comité de alto nivel integrado
por el Papa Francisco por el Primer
Ministro de India nadindra modi y por el
secretario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez para plantear una especie de
tregua de cinco años para que cesen las
hostilidades y para que las las naciones
pudieran recuperarse de la crisis post
pandemia el presidente López Obrador
sostuvo que la postura de México era
ciertamente la de rechazar las
intervenciones dijo que México ha sido
víctima de intervenciones en el pasado y
en ese sentido Pues quería crear esta
especie de comité no tuvo éxito el
presidente cuestionó que pues se
privilegian intereses Y de alguna manera
hubo también críticas a este plan de paz
por ejemplo mijailo podolia asesor de
Vladimir Putin cuestionó severamente
este plan de López Obrador dijo que era
un plan prorruso porque pretendía que
mantener a millones bajo ocupación y dar
tiempo a Rusia a que renovara sus
reservas para la siguiente ofensiva De
tal suerte pues que no no prospero Esa
esa idea Mario entonces entendiendo ya
este contexto Cuál es la posición de
México frente a la guerra en Ucrania
Cuál es la posición que tiene el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
si bien pues a México condenado la
invasión Incluso en la más reciente
votación de la asamblea general México
votó a favor de condenar la ocupación de
exigir el retiro de las tropas Lo cierto
es que no ha adoptado una postura como
lo quisiera por ejemplo la embajadora de
Ucrania en México oxana dramaretzka que
ha dicho pues en reiteradas ocasiones
que México debiera sumarse a las
sanciones económicas al embargo al
bloqueo y también ha llegado a sugerir
que México debería romper relaciones una
un episodio muy interesante fue a raíz
de la masacre de bucha en abril cuando
la embajadora cuestionó si México quería
seguir siendo o teniendo relaciones de
amistad con genocidas en el kremlin
López Obrador ha dicho que que no va a
contribuir a las sanciones económicas
porque la relación la postura de México
es tener relaciones buenas con todos los
países
incluso también ha cuestionado el envío
de armas recientemente cuando Alemania
decidió enviar sus tanques leopard pues
López Obrador dijo que lo hizo más
motivado por la presión de los medios de
comunicación alemanes porque en realidad
a decir de López Obrador la mayoría de
la población alemana no estaba de
acuerdo con el envío de más armamento a
la zona de conflicto en ese sentido
Bueno pues la postura sigue siendo la de
la pacifista la de no contribuir al
envío de tanques a la aplicación de
sanciones económicas y procurar sobre
todo el diálogo Aunque claro esta
táctica pues no no ha logrado rendir
frutos hasta